[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soder and the
daily telegraph's chief political
correspondent christopher hope welcome
to both of you with us i know until just
before midnight
from pages then let us start with the
guardian it leads with the release of a
video showing boris johnson's former
press spokesperson allegra stratton
joking with colleagues last year about a
christmas party downing street insists
never happened during severe covered
restrictions
the metro calls the laughing officials
number 10 party clowns
the daily mail refers to the incident as
a sick joke
the mirror with an exclusive reporting
that the education secretary gavin
williamson broke covert rules by holding
a staff party just before christmas last
year his spokesperson has admitted it
and has said the incident was
unfortunate the express says we should
all get our covered boosters now as
fears grow that the omicron variant
could overwhelm the nhs
the eye suggests it's beginning to look
a lot like last christmas with both the
westminster and scottish governments
hinting at work from home guidance being
reintroduced
telegraph has the same lead story also
reports the cabinet are divided over the
idea of vaccine passports
the times also reporting that ministers
are split on the potential use of
compulsory vaccine certification during
yesterday's cabinet meeting
the stars front page claims deputy prime
minister dominic raab is out of his
depth
over his handling of the taliban's
takeover of afghanistan the sun
criticizes energy bosses who appeared in
front of a panel of mps in response to
storm irwin sorry it's the wrong kind of
wind and the financial times understands
the us government has urged its german
counterparts to block a russian gas
pipeline if moscow decides to invade
ukraine
so let's bring in sonia soda and
christopher hope and apart from the last
two christopher that was a very
depressing set of headlines for downing
street was it not now this video if we
look at the metro and the other
newspapers number 10 party clowns this
was allegra stratton rehearsing for her
future role with a prospective question
about a potential party a fictional
party she calls it um is it fair to say
that they were referring to a real event
do you think is that absolutely obvious
from this
well you might assume that was the case
uh the it was it was a staged question
from a number 10 aide about the aide
said to allegra stratton um there's been
a party um we've seen on twitter it was
two days ago and he commented lego
stratton and she was preparing for this
new role that never happened to being
the prime minister's spokesman on tv um
and she was laughing about it and joking
um
you know i mean i think this is like
this is absolutely awful i mean i think
this is this is a moment when around
about how number 10 has handled itself
during the pandemic has completely cut
through to ordinary people this has
shades of the 2001 um good data very bad
news uh labor aid when when 9 11 attacks
were happening i think this is a moment
when people might think this is enough
and we need more professionalization in
number 10 dining street because it's a
shocking thing i think to see this video
it
will be seen as an insult to many who
didn't see family members and they died
last christmas because of the rules
brought in
um and i think this was gonna get it's
all run and run and it's a completely
self-inflicted uh wound by number ten
they could have clarified there was an
event this happened that happened that
they said they've held the line that it
was all within the rules in fact at one
point saying there was no party i saw
recently um i think
there's been a lot of um well a big
hangover in number 10 tomorrow morning
yes sorry just to clarify they need
you know a more professional approach
now because of the way they've handled
this um that summer ledger is a cover-up
or because of indications from this
video about how it was operated a year
ago which which are you talking about i
think
i think both i think culturally
looking at them laughing and snickering
about rules which were enforced by law
on the rest of the country is appalling
just appalling um culture
there's a problem there maybe that was a
year ago it might have changed new
people are there people move on et
cetera et cetera but i mean i i don't
know how people are going to react to
this in the morning i think if my
twitter thailand
is any any hint of that it's gonna be a
very difficult morning for us johnson
don't forget it's prime minister's
questions tomorrow kiestama legend this
last week he'll do it again and maybe
his backbench mps will also for boris
johnson yeah i'm sure we'll come on to
afghanistan as well uh also awkward
today uh sonia
but you know what impression is this
giving a sort of cavalier attitude um
you know how will people
take away
this sniggering about a potential party
um and the denials that we've had about
it
i think it comes across as not only
hypocritical but really callous i
completely agree with christopher about
the sacrifices that people made i mean
we made sacrifices in our family um
there were people who couldn't visit
their loved ones in in hospital
in um in care homes and went without
seeing their relatives there were people
who had relatives who were recently
grieved and they couldn't see them
either so i think it's going to be very
damaging for the government and the
reason why i think it's just as if not
more perhaps damaging than barnard's
castle
is we didn't have a video of dominic
cummings kind of laughing and snickering
and then practicing lines uh to deceive
the public which is how this comes
across
so i think it's really you know i think
people are going to be very very angry
about this and quite rightly so
um i think actually the fact how much
popular cut theory is getting through is
shown by the fact that tonight you've
got ant and deck uh on i'm a celebrity
their social media clip it referred to
this um and you know that that clip on
twitter has had almost a million views
um so i think it just goes to show that
that people are really sitting up and
paying attention and they're not happy
and understandably so it it smacks of a
government who didn't think that the
rules apply to them and i think it's
just the laughing about it as well it
just looks so bad
uh the financial times um has a quote in
response to the footage johnson's
spokesperson said there was no christmas
party covered rules have been followed
at all times uh one downing street
official the ft says it's pretty
disastrous the government and pm denying
it and then this footage leaks out
saying otherwise
um
you know what happens next because the
real concern is you bring in more rules
which we'll come to in a minute to deal
with the omicron variant or indeed delta
and people look at you and go well hang
on a minute is that is there a you know
a public
a public awareness issue here now as we
try to stay safe from from covid
christopher
i think people who work in number 10
are privileged people they have a
privileged power
over our lives and they should remember
that and they should look like they
remember that and not not uh not snigger
and laugh about an alleged party that
may or may not have happened and was
there wine and cheese was it a business
meeting it's a complete disgrace it's a
middle finger to the entire country i
think which is anticipating a difficult
christmas more restrictions across the
country certainly in scotland we saw
today work from home and that may well
happen down in england england no doubt
we're having a review of the plans in
about 10 days time on i expected in in
10 days time when they look at what they
found out by the government scientists
about about omicron it completely
undermines the messaging it's just
disgraceful frankly
so to the telegraph then we've already
heard from nicola sturgeon about working
from home here is the telegraph now
sonia suggesting that plans for working
from home around christmas are being
drawn up by the government as boris
johnson considers tougher measures to
slow the spread of the omicron variant
officials working on coveted policy have
carried out modeling on the economic
impact of urging people to work from
home over the festive period which i
guess itself is a natural circuit
breaker as many people are not in work
so here we are then the next stage of
having to bring in some restrictions uh
just at a time where we see what
happened possibly last christmas in
downing street
that's right and i think it probably
won't be a surprise to anyone that the
government is modeling the impact of
doing this that's quite reassuring in
some ways no decisions have been taken
yet apparently the times is reporting
that apparently it was discussed in the
cat in cabinet today and uh there are
divisions about what should happen but
the measures that we're talking about i
think it's important just to remind
people are much more incremental than
the sort of lockdown that we were
talking about last year and that is
because of vaccines so they um you
people may remember that government the
government's plan b which was always a
sort of thing that it held in reserve
for this winter it included masks which
you've already got compulsory masks but
the other two things were working from
home
and um uh also something else that's
just escaped me oh yes
passports of course um for nightclubs
and large events and venues and i don't
think it's it it will come as a surprise
that the government is looking at
introducing these we've had new news
about omicron out today as you were just
saying in your news bulletin at the top
of the hour
the emerging evidence does suggest that
omicron is more transmissible um
thankfully it looks like although it's
not as good the vaccines don't provide
as good protection against infection as
they do against um delta and indeed
earlier strains um thankfully it looks
like we hope that vaccines should still
provide a good level of protection
against uh hospitalization severe
illness and death so that's reassuring
at least but i think with it being more
transmissible the thing that the
government will be thinking about and
modeling is if you've got very large
numbers of infections and some people
you know predicting is always very
difficult but some people are predicting
infections of kind of up to 80 000 a day
um you know in a few weeks time then
even with vaccines
helping us and preventing severe disease
in a lot of people they're not 100
effective so if you've got very large
numbers of cases um you know a small
proportion of a very large number of
cases that can be enough to put a lot of
pressure on the nhs and the one
situation that we absolutely have to
avoid is the nhs getting completely
overwhelmed so it can't do other forms
of treatment you know when we're already
seeing those trade-offs being made for
example out of the booster program
about can i say
estonia is totally correct in all she
said there the one caveat is we are not
yet seeing um lots of people being
hospitalized by omicron yet and it may
be we don't it maybe we don't um i think
it's spreading quite a lot from
anecdotally amongst students and schools
and if that's brought back to families
at christmas there could be issues about
family mixing maybe but i i just think
we should need to make sure we have that
caveat at all points there's no no
evidence of of mass hospitalizations
just yet okay and uh what you were
quoting uh sonia there on vaccine escape
was from our scientific tom clark who'd
spoken to alex siegel a south african
scientist the african health research
institute who had tested live omicron
variant sample against plasma of people
twice vaccinated with pfizer and found
that antibodies were up to 40 fold less
effective at neutralizing omicron than
against the original curvature strain
between 20 and 40 times
less effective so we will watch this
space and no doubt get more data that
was on a small sample so that is the
caveat on that but uh everybody's
desperate for news aren't they uh to see
that maybe real world news too
plenty was still to come uh did the
prime minister get too personally
involved in the airlifting of animals
from afghanistan when human lives were
on the line discussing that in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now sonia soda and
christopher hope let's move to
afghanistan testimony heard today before
the foreign affairs select committee
so many issues about the warning of it
whether there was staffing to man the
telephone lines whether the emails were
read and the bit picked up by the
guardian how closely linked boris
johnson was
was the decision to airlift animals out
of afghanistan and did that actually
mean that people didn't get on flight
sonia
well i think this was the most explosive
bit to come out today actually and it
turns out that as a guardians reporting
that boris's parliamentary private
secretary actually wrote a letter to the
uh charity in question um reassuring
them that not only their staff would get
out but um that animals would be able to
get out as well and it was 150 cats and
dogs that were airlifted out of
afghanistan allegedly you know on on the
say-so of boris johnson after boris
johnson's intervention we know that the
um the defense secretary was not um was
was trying to block this he got
overruled it it's very likely that it
was the prime minister and this letter
just adds to that really and i just
think it's i mean it's just
god's
you know it's gobsmacking i'm kind of
lost for words we have people in
afghanistan who work with british troops
who worked as trans
they didn't all get out it was chaos um
it really doesn't sound like the
operation was well run at all and yet
there were british officials to help
shepherd this pain playing through i
think it's disgraceful and i mean all
revealed in dramatic testimony by chris
bryant who unveiled this letter who had
been sent to him during that during the
hearing today christopher and we'd
already heard the denials that this
plane was nothing to the government it
was chartered by the organization itself
it only happened after the conclusion of
the airlift of the people therefore
therefore
no human being could have gotten that
flight instead of the animals but
nonetheless
you know question marks raised surely
well well definitely i mean why on earth
is the pps the prime minister right into
a charity um going around the backs of
of all of government and the pps i mean
no one knows correctly who trudy
harrison is she looks after relations
with mps in the house of commons tory
mps at that that's all it shows a
personal involvement by boris johnson um
a slightly older one also not to use any
of the any of the any of the state
infrastructures to do to do it
and i think at the time this is played
out in real time with um
ben uh wallace on twitter um calling him
why am i you know almost saying why am i
saving this guy's pets he called them
pets by the way not rescue animals pets
when i've got people lives i need to
save not not animals um this
underlines that how it appears to be
appears to be a number 10 direct
intervention to make it happen another
issue here for boris johnson a day of
orcs hashtag orcs for the government
today
yeah
lots more on that no doubt in the coming
days you fear for the government on this
one christopher hope and sonia soda
thank you both very much indeed